all right well hello francesca and
welcome to the world of below deck
hi thank you very much i'm so happy to
be here
how did below deck come to you below
deck came to me
at such a good time i was leaving the
boat
that i was working on for the for
the past couple of years and um i just
needed some time
and i wanted a little i wanted a new
experience you know something that i
could
sink my teeth into and um yeah it just
it just popped up and it was it was like
it was meant to be is it something you
sought out or did someone be like
with someone like hey i think you could
be a good fit for the show i was sort
out
um i have to say yes uh i didn't i
didn't
chase this but um i'm so happy that it
came to me especially you know
in times like this i think that it's
important to just grab every new
experience that comes your way
yeah little did you know how much the
world was gonna change after you said
yes to this experience
i know crazy i hear coronavirus is a
thing
oh my god it's crazy i can't get any
hand sanitizer
so it's really bad the world's going to
hell in
handbasking were you a fan of the show
before
you signed up for it or what's your
relationship to the show before you
joined it i did watch it i was a little
i was a fan um but uh yeah i wasn't
um i was super busy also working on the
yachts as well
you are stepping into some big shoes
here
did you know kind of the hole that was
left that you were stepping into with
kate chastain leaving and
was there pressure involved i think
first of all she probably has smaller
feet than i do because
i'm taller than her but
you know from what i've seen kate
do on the show and how she works she's a
fantastic chief stew
you know i don't think you can compare
the two of us i think we both have
uh different work experience backgrounds
on yachts and off yachts
so i don't think that um comparing the
two but
she's she's a fantastic chief stu and
from what i saw she
you know she left the team really well
and you know she's got a great sense of
humor
but i went into there um just doing the
best that i could
and you know with the skills that i have
and the work experience that i have and
you know i believe that i could you know
do the best job that i can
the fans are inevitably gonna compare
you to her there's kind of no avoiding
it but what what do you want them to
know about who you are
and what the differences are between you
and kate i think we're just we're
totally different people we've also
grown up in different worlds you know
she's from the us
i'm from australia you know we operate
differently
we've grown up differently but um i
think the thing that we do have in
common is
i think working really hard and earning
respect
from your peers and captain and that
takes time
and she has had you know a lot of time
five
six years on me on the show um to be
able to do that as well
and um you know everyone's first time
can be rocky
and um you know but you can only put
your best foot forward that's something
that also we have in common i think that
you know we can only do our best and um
yeah i see where the wind takes us
hopefully not in the water
yeah hopefully not i can't do this all
myself
having seen some of the show and then
lived
what it's like to make the show what
surprised you the most between
those experiences i didn't realize how
much i
bloody cried
no i'm not a crier either that's very
you know all my um my girlfriend saw the
trailer and people that i've worked with
and like what are you doing have you
ever seen you like this before
that was very surprising i think there
was it was a lot of pressure you know
being my first time
we do see you get pushed to what almost
seems like a breaking point
what can you tell me about what leads up
to that moment
well i can't tell you too much but i
definitely didn't get enough sleep
um or eat anything or drink any water
and
i think that that with
no sleep water or food really like
you know would have set anybody off so
yeah but i mean i'm only human so
you know and that shows that as well you
know it's obviously
to be a chief student you need to be as
professional as possible
but um you know at least it didn't
happen in front of the guests
this is true uh looks like it may be
happening in front of the captain though
look that's fine you know um we you know
captain lee and i you know it's a
work in progress relationship you know
working relationship you can't
you know all of a sudden have trust and
um
you know rely on each other you know
it's a two-way street really isn't it
i don't mind that it happened in front
of him as much as
like what is going on there's no crying
in yachting how would you say
season eight is different from what
we've seen before oh well
i think there's a different type of
drama
there's no um violence or
you know there's nothing like that in it
i'm so excited
for them to see lots of laughs i think
there are a lot of yachting firsts
i mean look for captain leigh as well he
even said it himself he said there's a
lot of yachting firsts for him and for
me
oh just everything it's such a great
season so much happened
there's like people in the water then
there's people naked
and it's just like every it seems like
everywhere i turned
you know on the boat there was something
like
going on like there was a surprise you
know you walk into the galley and then
it's hitting the fan or then you walk
upstairs and then there's a naked china
guest and then there's someone
it was just like okay nothing's too
crazy
i'm just gonna like act like
everything's normal
would you want to go back and do another
season you know i would
100 i i would do another season because
i think that
captain lee and i towards there and
um you know had a great working
relationship
and uh you know that trust and respect
was earned
and also i think that i could just nail
it even better
you know when you do something once and
you're like great
down packed got it don't keep my eyes
closed now
maybe with one eye yeah
uh all right to wrap things up here if
you had to
boil your first below deck experience
down into just
one word what is your word for this
season of the show
oh gosh okay one word mind blowing
surprise wait i'll take a mind blowing
to hyphenate a word and then i'll take
surprise i'll take
two and a half words francesca i will
take it
surprise yeah no it's fantastic it's fun
it's energetic
there's something crazy that happens
every single charter it's so fun
you